this video is sponsored by the book
summary app blinkist
the intimations of it can and do spur
throughout the day both subtle and
explicit often without our conscious
awareness every sensation of hunger
every concern about our health every
passing siren of an ambulance every
tragic news story every photograph of
our younger self or the sight of someone
aged into their last the passing of dead
trees in the midst of winter that weird
sensation waking up just following a nap
or in between sleep states all remind us
in various ways that existence stands on
a ground that can at any uncertain
moment and certainly at some be cracked
open dropping us down into the abyss of
non-existence
forever death is our lifelong opponent
always taunting us in the background
beating us up with each wrinkle each
gray hair each stiff neck and decaying
function if we are lucky and is merciful
enough to keep us around for a while
like a tree its roots sprawl down
underneath existence imperceptible to us
on the surface void of the explicit
expression of our life but yet is
completely intertwined with it
arguably nearly everything we do is in
some sense pressed up on by these roots
our actions our beliefs our values our
goals our life
in his book the denial of death 20th
century cultural anthropologist and
writer ernest becker argued that death
and more precisely our denial of death
is the primary underpinning motivational
force responsible for the majority of
human behavior
as humans one of the fundamental things
that set us apart and forward amongst
other earthly creatures is our unique
ability to think conceptually becker
argued however that although this in
fact does set us apart and makes us feel
as though we are special in some grand
way it does not actually make us so
man is a worm and food for worms this is
the paradox he is out of nature and
hopelessly in it he is dual up in the
stars and yet housed in a heart-pumping
breath-grasping body that once belonged
to a fish and still carries the gill
marks to prove it
becker wrote
consequently humanity finds itself with
a unique conflict the juxtaposition of
its awareness of itself and its
condition a living thing born to die
like all other living things and its
lack of any reason or specialness to
justify this awareness
man is given no other significance or
consolation for this burden he must bear
what does it mean to be a self-conscious
animal becker writes the idea is
ludicrous if it is not monstrous
it means to know that one is food for
worms this is the terror to have emerged
from nothing to have a name
consciousness of self deep inner
feelings and excruciating inner yearning
for life and self-expression and with
all this yet to die
it seems like a hoax
whether we are aware of it or not
according to becker this terror of death
and more specifically our denial of
honestly responding to and accepting it
is at the core of almost everything we
do and most of us are mostly unaware of
it
the conscious mind cannot square the
circle of the approaching abyss it
cannot make sense of the idea that this
is its only serving of forever in its
inept confusion over its finitude into
infinite nothingness it fears it it
resists it it uses the same conceptual
capacity that allows it to comprehend
its death to contrive methods and
explanations to try to deny it
as becker would refer to it the
individual undertakes a kazo sui project
or heroism project in an attempt to
distract and deny against the
implications of their mortality we
create and engage in symbolic constructs
cultural activities and beliefs in an
attempt to refuse our cosmic
insignificance and convince ourselves
that we matter
becker suggested that people go about
this a number of ways depending on the
person for some it is through religion
for others it is through different means
of cultural contribution and status like
fame success in a career field or
company or the creation of things
considered significant by culture
all methods in some way or another
attempt to eternalize the self either by
a literal eternal afterlife or by the
displacement of the self through an
eternalized legacy and significance in
the world beyond one's physical
existence
however becker essentially argued that
ultimately all efforts towards this kaza
sui or heroism or immortality project
are futile and destined to fail with the
belief of religious afterlives and
solutions increasingly being eclipsed by
modern knowledge and understanding man
finds himself unable to do anything
ultimately significant or immortalizing
as the universe is revealed to be
utterly chaotic indifferent and
meaningless
becker offered no consolation in the way
of resolving humanity's urge to heroism
in conflict with its plight of
insignificant finitude because he did
not believe there was any and so what
does one do from here then
for becker it is not purely hopeless
what he offered rather was an
alternative kind of heroism
characterized by a sort of honesty with
one's condition living with an intense
humility and positive resignation to the
awe and mystery and chaos of the
universe and our insignificant position
within it
this position our absurdity our
victimization by our own death can be
transmuted in a way that does not deny
it but rather provides perspective
honest perspective that can reduce and
numb one's concerns over the petty and
trivial potentially deviating or
extending beyond becker slightly perhaps
the best one can do in the face of death
is to use it to put the life they have
into perspective perhaps we don't think
about it enough at least consciously to
properly make use of it to strengthen
the muscle of our mind enough to handle
its true inevitable weight
perhaps to consider somewhat often and
hard that at some point none of this
will matter and that it will all be lost
shines a proportionally bright light on
what does matter right now
when it comes to life and death there
are really only two certainties you will
die
but you are alive now
whether you agree fully with becker or
not whether you believe in some
afterlife or grand meaning this is all
anyone can truly know for sure there is
no telling if or what comes after death
there is no telling when it will come
for you but there is telling that you
have life right now
to enjoy fully this moment now as often
as you can in as many ways as you can to
fall in love with a person a thing a
moment yourself to make the most of it
all despite knowing that you will lose
it all to nothing is more than enough
heroism what's worse than to live a life
knowing that one will die is to live a
life knowing that one will die and not
live as many moments as one can properly
relishing in the fact that they have not
yet
at some point you will do everything for
the last time you will see your last
sunset you will taste your last bite of
food you will laugh your last laugh you
will see everyone you know a last time
you will do anything for a last time you
will be you for the last time
if there is nothing specific to be done
the only thing that truly matters is
that we do what matters to us while we
can
there is nothing else to do nowhere else
to go we must charge headlong into the
absurdity embrace the futility and live
hard for nothing in every moment
one must be careful and mindful to not
make the singularness of their shodded
existence a pressure to get it all right
to do all the right things and think all
the right thoughts and feel all the
right feelings
the point is quite the opposite you will
mostly do a lot of the wrong things
think a lot of the wrong thoughts and
feel a lot of the wrong feelings but
precisely because this is your one shot
at life this must be okay
you are driving blind through the most
impossibly complex strange maze that you
know ends in a head-on collision with
the wall what use is getting more upset
or guilty about feeling upset or guilty
in an existence that sets you up
of course this is far easier said than
done but perhaps in true deep
contemplations of one's mortality at
least on occasion this reminder can
sometimes serve more as a sedative and
not merely a stimulant
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blinkist
of course a life made and confined by
time means that we both have a limited
amount of it and have to spend it in
every moment
understandably this can create an
intense pressure for how we choose to do
so we can of course never fully do so
perfectly but the more methods and tools
we can use to protect and optimize it
obviously the better
specifically reading is both an
extremely important and extremely
difficult habit in this regard its value
is immense but it can generally be a
slow and tedious spend of time however
whether you're already a reader who
wants to better optimize the habit or
someone who wants to start reading more
in general but has struggled to do so
for this reason of time the book summary
app blinkist helps solve these problems
by allowing you to read and learn from
far more books and far less time
blinkist allows you to do this by
condensing thousands of complete
non-fiction books into around 15-minute
summaries which can be both read and
listened to even while offline
if you read just one hour per day and it
roughly took you as an average reader
about 1.7 minutes to read one book page
if you are reading a traditional
complete book you would learn from only
about 35 pages of the one book with
blinkist however in that same hour you
would learn from about four complete
books extracting all the main ideas
overviews and key takeaways in the same
amount of time of course you're getting
condensed versions but with the amount
of time saved you'll have all the more
room and be all the better equipped to
determine the right books and topics to
go on and read more fully about and now
for these cases blinkist also has
full-length audio books that can be
purchased directly within the app as
well as unique consolidated summaries of
popular podcasts if you're interested in
learning more about anthropology and the
influence and effects of human behavior
blinkist has excellent titles like
sapiens by yaval noah harari and the
third chimpanzee by jared diamond as
well as many more in 26 other categories
the first 100 people to use the link in
the description will receive one free
week of unlimited access as well as 25
percent off of full membership the free
7-day trial can be canceled at any time
within the trial period
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you